[Music]
the massacre of Israeli civilians by
Hamas a Palestinian group and Israel's
subsequent retaliation is the latest
bloody eruption of a long-running
conflict between Israel and the
Palestinians this conflict has its
origins in a letter written more than
100 years ago and just 67 words
[Music]
long in 1917 Arthur balfor the British
foreign secretary typed in note that
would change the face of the Middle East
the letter was a declaration of support
for zionists who wanted to create a
Jewish state in the carve up of the
Ottoman Empire after the first world war
the League of Nations gave Britain a
mandate to rule
Palestine the Arabs who had been living
there for centuries turned increasingly
to resistance and violence culminating
in a Revolt in
1936 the British crushed the uprising
but tried to win over the Arabs by
restricting Jewish
Ambitions after Jewish anger also turned
violent the British gave up they handed
the problem over to the United
Nations in 1947 the UN voted to
partition Palestine but the Arabs
rejected this and fighting broke out
once
again the last British soldiers left
Palestine in May 1948 Within hours
Jewish leaders declared the
establishment of the state of
Israel neighboring Arab countries
invaded
immediately in the Armistice of 1949 the
land was divided between Israel and Arab
states but there was no new state for
the Palestinians just two regions
controlled by Egypt and Jordan now known
as Gaza and the West
Bank an estimated 700,000 Palestinians
fled or were pushed out of their homes
they called this the nakba the
catastrophe since then there have been
Wars uprisings terrorist attacks and
diplomatic deals nothing has brought
lasting peace or a state for the
Palestinians since the war of 1967 many
Palestinians have lived in the West Bank
under Israeli
occupation today they're cut off by the
Israeli security barrier
they have autonomy in big cities and
towns but are surrounded by Jewish
settlements others are locked away in
Gaza this densely populated strip of
land has been the scene of repeated
battles a grim pattern that seems
destined to
[Music]
continue